[Música]
eu não sabia que filho de traficantes
tentava dinheiro do tráfego nas redes
sociais
eu não sabia que macaco voava
eu não sabia que gorila falava inglês
mostra pra mim
a foto daquele velho que está pagando
sua passagem
quando fui colocar o meu primeiro vídeo
nas redes sociais eu queria só mostrar
cinco lugares de nova york que eu mais
gosto
o meu sonho era ser um blogueiro de
viagens juro para vocês sabem que eles
ganham viagem faz aquelas fotos de gente
estamos aqui não é eu queria ser esse
blogueiro linho e aí eu tinha várias
histórias de várias idéias de vários
lugares que eu queria viajar mas eu
gravei aquele vídeo coloquei no ar cheio
de expectativa e quando eu acordei a
primeira coisa que eu recebi
foram estas mensagens que eu te conto e
agora foi isso
eu fechei o meu canal
levei um susto e comecei a pesquisar
como eu poderia combater tudo aquilo que
eu estava vendo ser construído na minha
frente e como eu não sabia responder se
acredita
foi a minha cor que eles viram quando eu
coloquei uma simples viagem para nova
york
peraí ele está realizando um desejo que
é meu
gente eu não sou a cor daquele jovem que
sai do brasil para em um parque de uma
pessoa vestida de ratazana da chapa
criança
quiçá de um jovem que vai passear em
nova york o nome disso é racismo
estrutural porque por conta da estrutura
eu não consigo enxergar menos visíveis
pelas quais aquele jovem está ali em
nova york
tirando fotos na times square
eu tenho um objetivo meu objetivo
começou ali entrar nas redes sociais de
usar minha voz para escrever e falar
sobre tudo aquilo que eu vi sendo
construído nas redes sociais através de
influenciadores que usavam aquela
plataforma para dizer que o negro
escravizou o próprio negro já ouviu pra
dizer que o negro é mais racista do que
o branco já ouviu pois foi isso
pessoas que não estudaram nada da nossa
história que não conhece nada da nossa
vivência que não sabem nada sobre a
realidade de ser negro nesse país
resolveram entrar nas redes sociais para
reinventar a história do negro nesse
país uma história que nunca foi contada
mas eles resolveram ter a última palavra
sobre a nossa história ea nossa dor
então eu entrei nas redes sociais pra
falar sobre racismo estrutural
mesmo não sendo o acadêmico da área de
história eu acho que eu tenho mais
propriedade para falar sobre a história
do meu povo do que eles e eu comecei a
pesquisar lê e aí eu queria te fazer uma
viagem eu queria fazer uma viagem com
vocês sobre racismo estrutural vem
comigo vem antola vou fazer uma linha do
tempo para explicar que racismo
estrutural não pode ser chamado de mini
houve otimismo
vamos pra 1824
tudo negro são considerados seres
semoventes e poderiam ser hipotecados a
casa ou em 1839 que um decreto no rio de
janeiro e que se espalha pelo brasil
inteiro impede que negros frequentem
escolas públicas ou então a 1850 quando
a lei de terras impede que negros
pessoas escravizadas ou não alforriados
livres tivessem acesso a terras a 1870
com a importação de imigrantes europeus
após o censo de 1872 e as leis para
inglês ver que não resolvem nada
em 1888 nós temos a lei da tal chamada
heroína a lei 3.353 descobriu o erro
imagina só entregaram nos às traças
mas em 1890 com o decreto 847 chamado
vadios e capoeiras pessoas que
praticassem religião de matriz africana
ou capoeira poderiam ser encarcerados
começa ali a história do encarceramento
de homens e mulheres negras nesse país
está acompanhando a estrutura pois em
1911 após a participação do brasil no
congresso mundial das raças liderado
pelo doutor joão batista de lacerda o
brasil traz uma ideia que a lei 9081 que
traz as primeiras cotas para brancos
nesse país e que institui que essas
pessoas vão ter direito a terras à
educação as colônias será que eu tô no
estado certo
as colônias para nós nada
em 1934 nós temos a primeira
constituição que traz eugenio na na
constituição artigo 38 parágrafo b diz o
seguinte fomentar a educação eugênica
branquear o país
acabar com gente como eu e é o primeiro
ano que os negros têm direito a voto
acredita em 1937 a frente negra
brasileira proibida e se torna ilegal o
grupo que falaria pelos negros e com os
negros se torna ilegal nesse país
em 1968 nós temos uma lei chamada lei do
boi a lei 5465 sabe que dizia lei do boi
50% das vagas nas universidades
agrícolas e depois se espalha isso são
destinados a pessoas que possuem terras
só em 1988
quatrocentos e oitenta e oito anos
depois de tudo que passamos é que
constitucionalmente o brasil vai
reconhecer que o racismo é crime
em 2001 da conferência de durban os
delegados cobram brasil uma postura em
relação às diferenças entre pretos e
brancos as desigualdades e aí o brasil
vai instituir as cotas primeiramente em
2002 após uma grande discussão mas só em
as cotas são aprovadas pelo supremo
tribunal federal desse país por
unanimidade mas tem gente que ainda
continuam discutindo com até hoje
chegamos a 2019 e entende que o racismo
é estrutural
houve uma estrutura que foi criada para
nos impedir de chegarmos até o lugar que
muitos brancos ocupam simplesmente por
serem brancos
fala pra mim que você não conhece um
branco incompetente
a nossa pauta é importante porque há
muitos meninos e meninas negras
competentíssimos dos quais nós ouvimos
aqui e vamos ouvir muito mais mas o
nosso país não deseja nos ouvir porque
foram os nossos avós
os bisavós tataravós que trabalharam
gratuitamente quase celi tendo
funcionado pra gente
nas casas de pessoas brancas desse país
ou seja a ordem e progresso significam
duas coisas completamente diferentes no
brasil
se você vê essa linha estrutural você
não é que ordem progresso significa a
ordem leis burocracia impedimento para
pretos pobres e favelados e progresso
pequenas cotas pequenas ajudinha para os
descendentes dos europeus que adoram
contar a sua história há como eles
gostam de falar que vão tirar um
passaporte europeu se tudo der errado
embora daqui
é ordem e progresso significam coisas
completamente diferentes e depois eu te
explicar tudo aqui sobre uma estrutura
do racismo a gente podia muito mais a
fundo
ainda vai ter coragem de deixar pessoas
dizerem que a nossa história a nossa dor
a nossa trajetória vai ser resumida em
duas palavras repetidas três vezes
nim não pode o brasil precisa acordar e
começar a prestar atenção que tem um
povo que conta a sua história todo dia e
ele conta sua história em cima dos
nossos corpos
negando todo o passado de uma estrutura
que fez com que esse país se
transformasse no que é hoje mas aí nós
estamos hoje como se estivéssemos nos
anos 60 nos estados unidos mas o que
aconteceu lá vários brancos reconheceram
que não era pessoal que o combate ao
racismo é coletivo e que na coletividade
dos brancos eles precisam reconhecer os
seus privilégios para que nós possamos
fazer uma caminhada em direção ao avanço
que nós precisamos nessa sociedade
brancos precisam entender que
coletivamente
eles ajudaram no sistema que nos oprimiu
mas que coletivamente
eles têm como responsável
responsabilidade moral de ajudar a
acabar com essa estrutura que você
acabou de ver esse pt
[Aplausos]
daqui a 60 anos
daqui a 60 anos bisneto os netos filhos
de muitos aqui vão perguntar
pai mãe de que lado o senhor a senhora
esteve vovó bisavô bisavó de que lado o
senhor a senhora esteve no momento em
que os negros brasileiros discutiram a
revolução de um país que precisava mudar
de que lado você esteve e aí você vai
poder olhar pra trás e falou assim eu
não silenciei quando houve o erro
acontecer quando eu estendi a estrutura
de um país
mentiroso e meritocrático eu não me
silêncio gay e cabe a nós começar a
discutir isso eu espero você do lado de
cá nos ajudando a refletir a mudar esse
país
eu tenho convite a fazer e vamos juntos
promover o processo civilizatório que
esse país tanto precisa
então vão
[Aplausos]